[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
cet après midi sur public sénat
poursuivre les travaux des sénateurs
avec une audition très importante cet
après midi qui concerne la fermeture des
commerces non essentiel pendant la
période de confinement c'est une
décision d' emmanuel macron confirmée
par le premier ministre jean castex mais
qui provoque la grogne des élus locaux
eh oui plusieurs maires ont pris ce week
end est arrêté pour ouvrir malgré tout
leurs commerces de proximité il dénoncé
l'inéquité avec les grandes surfaces et
en réaction le premier jean castex a
annoncé que dès demain les rayons de
produits non essentiels dans les grandes
surfaces seraient fermés pour revenir
sur cette polémique également sur les
mesures de soutien aux petits
commerçants le ministre chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises est
auditionné cet après midi par le sénat
je vous laisse écouter son audition en
outre la roche de cette période de huit
semaines stratégique avant les fêtes les
inquiète fortement
ils craignent de ne pas pouvoir
surmonter l'épreuve que représenterait
des mouvements de fin d'année et ceci
malgré les aides que vous apprêtez
rapporté il rappelle notamment que le
clic en colère ou la vente en ligne ne
représente qu'une très faible
compensation en termes de chiffre
d'affaires
le premier ministre a donc annoncé hier
soir deux mesures la première est la
fermeture dans les grandes surfaces
après les rayons livres de tous les
rayons non essentiels au nom de l'équité
concurrentielle
ce choix interroge monsieur le ministre
puisqu'il prive de débouchés certains
producteurs les auteurs les éditeurs les
fournisseurs de textiles les producteurs
de fleurs de sapins tout en augmentant
en rien le chiffre d'affaires des petits
commerces
ce n'est donc évidemment pas une
solution optimale bien au contraire
j'ajoute que mobiliser des forces de
l'ordre pour aller vérifier demain la
bonne application des consignes dans les
supermarchés nous semble pas être une
priorité
la seconde mesure est une clause de
revoyure et la possibilité de rouvrir
certains magasins dans deux semaines si
la situation le permet et j'imagine dans
certaines conditions il nous paraît
essentiel est très urgent seul ministre
d'entendre et demande des commerçants
d'entendre cette contestation est de
tenter de l'apaiser notamment
souplesse quand la situation de perdre
nous semble également qu'il fallait
dépasser l'opposition frontale trop
souvent mise en avant entre grandes
surfaces sites marchands et commerces de
proximité les acteurs économiques
fournisseurs français l'ont grandes ou
petites entreprises ont toutes besoin de
tous les circuits de distribution
bien entendu tous les acteurs dans la
valse op tous sont mobilisés contre le
développement du virus qui contamine 46
mille personnes par jour cent mille
professeurs de phase i et qui va
vraisemblablement vos prochaines
semaines saturé notre système de soins
dans toutes les régions
aussi sont ils prêts à beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'adaptations pour passer ce
cap
nous avons donc souhaité échanger avec
vous très rapidement le sionisme et je
vous remercie d'avoir répondu
favorablement à notre demande dans les
délais si courts
l'objectif de cette audition et
d'expliquer la réponse du gouvernement à
ces contestations et de préciser les
nouvelles mesures de soutien que vous
comptez mettre en oeuvre pour soutenir
le pm à titre personnel je souhaiterais
partager un avis puis vous poser deux
questions
un avis d'abord après des deux mesures
annoncées je vois aujourd'hui 3 risque
de concentration des risques au premier
la concentration des risques dans
l'espace avec seulement quelques
magasins ouverts des courses de noël
vont physiquement se resserrer dans eu
de magasins cette concentration des
acheteurs est elle vraiment préférable à
leur répartition sur un nombre important
de points de vente
la concentration des risques dans le
temps maintenant dans cette période
stratégique de fin d'année les courses
de noël se feront donc au mieux sur
quatre semaines au lieu de huit
favorisant ainsi la densification des
clients dans les magasins troisième
risque enfin la concentration des tâches
et des personnels dans les entrepôts de
logistique et le transport duick au
ventre qui vont être pris d'assaut
au delà de l'heure et de leurs
espérances les français n'ayant plus ce
canal distribution disponibles
je me questionne donc sur l'efficacité
réelle du dispositif pour lequel vous
avez un mais deux questions maintenant
les commerçants ont ils suffisamment et
tait associé aux décisions prises sur
seconde confinement ont regardé risque
avéré de seconde vague
aviez-vous construit avec eux au coeur
de l'été un plan de prévention des
risques de contamination pour envisager
ces fermetures
leurs modalités leurs alternatives la
seconde question porte sur la suite
le gouvernement avait rejeté la
possibilité ouverte par le cénacle de
préfets en fonction des circonstances à
lithaire locales puissent décider de la
réouverture de certains commerces
sous réserve de précaution sanitaire
renforcée
cela signifie t'il que le gouvernement
n'envisage aucune adaptation locale des
règles en vigueur
même si la situation sanitaire ici ou là
permettrait d'apporter de l'air aux
commerçants je vous laisse maintenant la
parole pour un propos liminaire
puis mes collègues sénateurs vous
poseront leurs questions en commençant
par serge babary qui est le rapporteur
des crédits liés au commerce et à
l'artisanat dans la mission économie dj
hero et qui est également président de
la délégation aux entreprises
monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes
merci madame la présidente
tout d'abord j'ai changé de pareilles
gt1 que maintenant ce qu'il dit le pour
tout le monde moi je ne vois pas remis à
temps qu'il ya les y écouter mes excuses
si c'est pas le cas on va continuer
d'essayer de progresser
tout d'abord vous remercier madame
président où il a salué les sénatrices
et les sénateurs présents et vous dire
que pour moi c'est à la fois un plaisir
mais également normal que je sois à
votre disposition dans cette situation
qui est extrêmement difficile pour tout
le monde et en premier lieu heures de
l'écho qui sont les premiers concernés
et qui subissent cette situation
tout d'abord dire que en ce qui concerne
mon de nommer rémois naturellement nous
avions tout fait en termes de prévention
en termes d'information pour essayer
d'envisager de permettre de garder
ouverts l'ensemble de ces entreprises
les éléments sanitaires sont venus avec
une force terrible compromettent ce que
nous souhaitions
effectivement il ya eu un arbitrage ou
regarder la tendance majeure de
contamination tous les jours et de
risques avérés
l'affluence dans les hôpitaux et de
débordement des services d'urgence
il y à une décision expliquée par le
poison de la république qui consiste au
minimum jusqu'au 1er décembre et avec
une clause de revoyure quinze jours
après de prendre des mesures de
restriction que le président a qualifié
lui-même de brutales pour espérer
d'arrêter la propagation du virus et
surtout d'espérer n'ont pas de passer un
noël normal mais au moins de permettre
aux français de pouvoir en décembre
faire leurs achats et aux professionnels
de pouvoir travailler dans les
meilleures conditions possibles pour
première éléments si vous permettez tout
d'abord je n'ai pas cessé depuis mon
arrivée au gouvernement le 6 juillet
d'avoir quasiment tous les jours des
rencontres avec les différents
responsables du commerce
ils sont nombreux n'empêche que je les
ai vus très régulièrement et nous avons
échangé sur tous les sujets avec eux de
façon à regarder comment passer cette
crise sanitaire qui parce qu'elle est à
votre celi terre et comment réussira à
tout faire pour que l'activité
économique s'est effondrée pas c'était
la position du gouvernement depuis le
mois de mars avec des mesures inégales
et en europe d'accompagnement des
entreprises ce qui
pas dire que tout va bien j'ai bien
conscience on regarde de mon parcours et
de la connaissance que je peux avoir de
ces secteurs que beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs sont en difficulté mais
en tout cas la date d'aujourd'hui la
date d'aujourd'hui on ne constate pas un
nombre de défaillances plus élevé qu'à
la même date les années précédentes ce
qui ne veut pas dire que ça va bien je
dis simplement de façon ponctuelle en
nombre de chiffres
on n'a pas de chiffres plus importants
deuxième élément il est évident que
quels que soient les efforts que nous
faisons ce plan financier fermer une
entreprise pour un artisan un commerçant
c'est un cache coeur et je voudrais
naturellement dire que cette fermeture
n'est en aucun cas de la part du
gouvernement une punition envers qui que
ce soit ils n'ont pas fauté ne sont pas
fautifs de la situation sanitaire
ils ont pour beaucoup d'entre eux
beaucoup beaucoup travaillé pour adapter
les east barrière mis en oeuvre des
procédures sanitaires extrêmement
complexes souvent après des protocoles
qui avait été négociée par leur
organisation est naturellement moi j'ai
pu constater et que ces hommes et ces
femmes avaient fait beaucoup d'efforts
pendant le premier confinement pour
réussir à contribuer à éviter de de
propager le virus est naturellement il
n'y a pas de la part de qui que ce soit
au gouvernement une volonté de nuire ces
entreprises
c'est pour ça que avant même l'annoncé
qui a été faite par le président j'avais
proposé aux abords de la mer au premier
ministre des mesures nouvelles amplifié
très fortement amplifié d'accompagnement
parce que je sais très bien que le
deuxième confinement est beaucoup plus
dure à supporter pour six entrepreneurs
d'abord moralement ensuite
financièrement et donc vous avez entendu
ce que ce qu'a dit le ministre de
l'économie
15 milliards d'euros pour le mois de
novembre un exemple très clair sur le
fond de solidarité que nous avons
simplifié en termes d'accès
nous sommes passés de 1500 euros ce qui
avait été sujet eux jugés souvent comme
étant assez satisfaisant nous passons
pour le mois de novembre dix mille euros
de compensation de chiffre d'affaires
donc nous avions ce que le plan
financier anticipé cette situation nous
avons beaucoup concertés et
naturellement pas satisfaisant
totalement je suis naturellement pas à
l'heure à l'heure à la minute
régulièrement ce qui se passe depuis
vendredi j'entends les revendications
les demandes les critiques et j'ai
repris dès aujourd'hui les contacts avec
les organisations pour une raison très
simple c'est que je pense que en tout
cas en ce qui me concerne nous avons
aucune garantie que le virus ne nous
colle pas aux basques encore pendant
plusieurs mois
et naturellement nous allons nous
n'allons pas pouvoir pendant plusieurs
mois continuer à mettre deux milliards
tous les mois et donc il faut absolument
que nous trouvions avec l'ensemble des
représentants j'ai toute une série de
rencontres dans les prochains jours avec
l'ensemble des non pas seulement des
reposes revue commerce mais de
l'ensemble des branches concernées des
réunions pour voir de quelle manière on
pourrait encore amener des éléments de
sécurité sanitaire au ministère de la
santé au conseil de défense pour
permettre de reprendre une activité est
compris dans une période sanitaire
compliqué avec un espoir je vous dis
mais ça n'est qu'un espoir de ma part
c'est que ce qu'a indiqué le président
comme étant une éventuelle possibilité
de clause de revoyure bien jours après
les annonces se traduisent en tout cas
je l'espère même si cet espoir et
minimes mais une reprise de l'activité
le premier ministre a annoncé hier la
fermeture dans la grande distribution
d'un certain nombre de d'éléments de
vente pour remettre à l'égalité l'équité
de traitement
les petits commerces à la grande
distribution
j'entends bien maintenant le président
que ce n'est pas satisfaisant
le fait de réduire l'activité de chacun
n'est pas un objectif
moi j'entends bien la volonté de chacun
c'est de travailler est ici à venir si
on ne peut que se féliciter de voir des
hommes et des femmes qui veulent
travailler
vous comprenez je pense aisément et
c'est notre volonté mais en tout cas
nous sommes je crois aujourd'hui par le
souci d'équité il était indispensable de
prendre cette décision et dans les
prochaines heures
un décret sorti robe pour préciser
exactement le type de produits qui vont
pouvoir continuer à être vendus dans la
grande distribution avec en termes de
communication en tout cas aux insiste
là-dessus je sais que beaucoup de petits
commerçants ont été blessés par une
meute terme de non essentielle
je ne l'utilisent pas malheureusement à
la presse le faire on prend quelquefois
moi je considère que le terme je sais
pas si c'est plus adapté en tout cas le
jour d'hui le moins blessant je crois
pour les commerçants c'est le fait de
dire qu'on privilégie tout ce qui
concerne la première nécessité les
produits de première nécessité qui peut
être compris et en tout cas le terme
dans l'essentiel de ma bouche et est
banni parce que je sais qu'il blesse et
qui correspond pas je pense à la
situation
donc la situation
c'est vrai compliqué moscou souhaite
qu'on explique vraiment très fortement
je faire beaucoup d'efforts pour ça à
l'ensemble des commerçants quels sont
les dispositifs qui sont à leur
disposition
on va les rendre très facile d'accès on
va les rendre très visibles de façon à
ce qu'ils puissent très vite en
bénéficier pour une solidarité
exonérations de cotisations sociales
activité partielle à 100%
ensuite nous avons décidé et bonello
mère de mette en place un fonds de 100
millions d'euros pour accompagner à la
fois les collectivités et les
entreprises pour ceux numérisés pour
digitaliser je sais bien que ce qui est
appelé le click and collect le comment
de retrait pour le dire plus en français
n'est pas à une compensation de sud à
faire ça n'est jamais qu'un complément
nous avons décidé que ce qui sera fait
par ce dispositif sera ne sera pas
déduit des 10000 euros de compensation
de chiffre d'affaires pour inciter les
commerçants les artisans à utiliser ces
dispositifs et moi je souhaite associer
le plus possible les régions les opci et
les communes pour qu'on puisse
développer ces dispositifs de façon à ce
que naturellement chacun p6 utiliser et
j'ai bien conscience que ces fermetures
de commerces et de partis de grande
distribution on va faire transiter une
partie de la consommation vers
l'économie en ligne même si
naturellement amazon n'est pas le seul
bénéficiaire mais naturellement est très
visible est souvent mis en avant pour ne
pas être trop long venant présidente et
et si ça vous convient
moi je suis disponible pour essayer de
répondre aux interrogations de
l'ensemble des sénatrices et des
sénateurs pour d'abord vous écoutez moi
je suis aussi à votre disposition parce
que les bonnes idées ne sont pas qu'à
bercy elles sont partout et qui plus est
dans les représentants des territoires
et je suis naturellement preneur de
propositions j'ai bien entendu votre
demande
concernant la proposition sénatoriale
qui a été voté au sénat
bon la position du gouvernement a été de
dire dans un premier temps qui
effectivement est souhaitée au regard de
la
gravité de la grille la crise sanitaire
d'avoir une mesure qui s'applique sur
tous les territoires avec le risque
effectivement que certains élus locaux
pour répondre à la demande des
commerçants aient tendance à en ouvrir
beaucoup et donc ne pas avoir les
mesures nécessaires ce qui est développé
par le ministère de la santé et le corps
médical s'est pas tellement que c'est à
l'intérieur du des petits commerçants
qu'on peut être contaminé mais c'est que
le nombre multiplié de lieu d'ouverture
génère plus de flux encore une fois je
suis totalement incompétent dans le
domaine de la santé
et je n'ai pas d'arguments
supplémentaires mais en tout cas c'est
l'argument qui a été mis en avant et qui
a justifié la fermeture de tous ces
points de commerce
voilà madame la présidente pas de pros
long mais les premiers éléments que je
souhaitais mettre à votre vessie
très bien merci de faire réagir à un
certain nombre college déjà beaucoup de
demandes et d'inscription je vais passer
la parole à daniel laurent ensuite à
franck mais nos villes et nos chers
collègues à la règle des deux minutes
voilà si vous pouviez à peu près la
respecte et je vous proposerai monsieur
le ministre peut-être faire ça une
question parce à une question pour est
un peu vivant daniel alors oui monsieur
le ministre madame la présidente andrée
j'espère depuis depuis l'annnonce du
confinement je ne compte pas
certainement comme tous les collègues
les messages de désespoir des
commerçants qui nous disent qu'ils ne
s'en relèveront pas oui la question
sanitaire et sans talent les commerçants
ont fait le maximum pour répondre aux
familles soyez clair il ne s'agit pas
d'opposer les commerçants indépendants
la moyenne et grande distribution il est
question équipement ni d'opposer la
sécurité sanitaire à l'économie déjà
fragilisé par le premier instrument de
cette décision de fermeture wagon
plus conduire inéluctablement le nombre
de commerces à la fermeture définitive
avec des conséquences psychosociales
emploi aménagement et dymanique nos
territoires il avait justement dit
monsieur le ministre le sénat vous avez
des propositions afin de déterminer les
conditions dans lesquelles les préfets
ont autorisé l'ouverture des commerces
dits non essentiels là il n'y avait pas
répondu
c'est bien dommage les chambres de
communes a aussi aidé l'industrie
demande d'étudier la proposition
d'autorisation d'ouverture sur rendez
vous quelle est votre position
ensuite il y à une incompréhension dans
les décisions prises et je l'aï déjà dit
qu'ils voulaient ils vous le concède
sont difficiles et inédite mais nous
savons où peuvent mener de sentiment
d'injustice sans compter les risques de
fracture dans notre pays qui sont déjà
fortement sous jacentes
vous avez parlé du flux du flux que
pourrait créer les commerces
il ya déjà un flux celles et ceux qui
vont travailler
donc je te fuis il existe donc il sera
pas complémentaires il sera associé dans
nos territoires ruraux monsieur le
ministre nous nous tenons déjà les
petites communes à bout de bras et
malgré cela il y en a déjà fermé avant
avant cette crise du bo vide
vous ne prenez pas conscience de ce qui
se passe dans nos campagnes
nous avons des petits commerces les
maires se bat pour les faire venir pour
les tenir et pour les faire vivre
ça va être la fin de ces petits
commerces et nous n'aurons plus que des
grandes surfaces ou internet avec amazon
et les eaux alors dans ce cas là c'est
aussi tous ses gaffes à amazon et les
autres enquêtes en fusion mais on en n'a
pas pu aller 7 10 et stabilisation pour
me servira à aider les petites communes
les petits commerces et si cela dure
trois mois monsieur le ministre je veux
pas être pessimiste mais quand j'en
parlais les millions du flambeau
explique demande comment on va faire
merci daniel je présente mes excuses à
ceux à qui j'ai oublié de donner la
parole en premier par dans serge la
pression de labellisation entreprise cet
automne la parole est ensuite france
mais nos vies pardon possible
merci président le fait le ministre
merci de nous permettre cet échange d
videmment qui a eu une extrême
importance pour tous et je vais très
évoqué deux thèmes que vous avez
indiquée dans votre propos liminaire
tout d'abord concernant les mesures de
soutien et puis ensuite la lumière
isation monsieur le ministre
outre l'élargissement du fonds de
solidarité et de reconduction des divers
exonérations fiscales et sociales
quelles sont les nouvelles mesures de
soutien aux commerçants que vous
envisagez de prendre pour ce deuxième
confinement en particulier pourriez vous
détailler le dispositif de crédit
d'impôt à destination des bailleurs qui
doit les inciter à renoncer à percevoir
les loyers
deuxième sujet sur la numérisation la
vente en ligne et le comment de retrait
qui comme collègues peuvent être de
précieux relais de croissance pour les
commerçants ce qui implique de changer
quelle est l'ampleur la politique de
numérisation des pme pour la rendre
réellement efficace vous annoncez 100
millions d'euros un cadre du plan de
relance ou et vous détailler leurs
usages notamment présenté leur
utilisation sous forme de crédits
d'impôts vous prévoyez en particulier 16
millions d'euros de plus pour
l'initiative france nîmes en espérant
réaliser ainsi environ 10000 diagnostic
de numérisation auprès des petits
entrepreneurs les besoins actuels ne
justifierait tic pas cet objectif de dix
mille soit fortement augmenté sa chaude
sûrement enfin comptez vous supprimez la
commission que perçoit la poste pour les
ventes réalisées sur la plateforme ma
ville mon shopping comme durant le
premier confinement y compris d'ailleurs
l'abonnement pour les collectivités je
vous remercie
merci franck mais non vie et vivre de
karaboué
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre merci de votre réactivité pour
dans un tel contexte
moi ma question elle est très simple
depuis ce week-end nous sommes assaillis
de break non des commerçants de
proximité du petit commerce dans nos
villes qui vivent ce que confinement et
7 heures de fermeture femme est le
véritable au maintien l'ouverture d'un
certain nombre de commerces et surtout à
la possibilité offerte et du risque de
report important vers le e-commerce et
notamment vous allez vous avez réagi et
le premier ministre a annoncé hier la
fermeture des rayons non essentiels dans
les grandes surfaces
la présidente l'a dit mais ça nous
semble et ça me sens vraiment une
une fois une une fausse bonne idée
puisque ça accenture est effectivement
le report inévitable vers le vers le
e-commerce donc les questions qui sont
les miennes aujourd'hui c'est plutôt de
voir avec vous et notamment vous
puissiez nous nous exposer les
alternatives que vous souhaitez mettre
en place pour rendre possible l'accès au
marché donc de ces commerces aujourd'hui
fermé c'est peut-être aussi d'entrevoir
des nouvelles opportunités d'ouverture
notre collègue daniel laurent l'a évoqué
mais c'est à dire accentué peut-être les
plages horaires de certains commerces
ont leur lot on individualise en leur
leur accès sur rendez vous et puis ces
deux également devoir peut-être ce qu'il
en matière de protocole ce qui pourrait
être ajoutée pour permettre l'accès à
l'ouverture d'un certain nombre de
commerces tout en rappelant qu'il n'est
pas plus dangereux d'aller chez un
commerçant de proximité sécurisé je sais
que nous pouvons dire sur le territoire
les et les commerces ont fait de
nombreux efforts pour sécuriser l'accès
assurer la sécurité de les usagers et
des consommateurs merci merci franck
kevin renaud garabédian est ensuite
ministre
merci mais la présidente monsieur le
ministre comme viennent de le dire mes
collègues
petits commerçants de pays ont
actuellement très peur que cette
deuxième que ce deuxième confinement
marque la fable va faire d'autant plus
qu'on vient d'entendre à l'instant par
une information que le rond confinement
risque de durer de huit à douze semaines
il existe aujourd'hui nos catégories de
petits chefs d'entreprise qui ne vont
pas survivre seul qui en théorie ne sont
pas empêché d'ouvrir mais dans
l'activité totalement paralysé je parle
de tout l'écosystème touristique
les hôteliers ne sont pas concernés par
le décret sur le confinement et 7 non
fermeture administrative les exclut de
fait d'une potentielle prise en charge
de leurs sinistres par les compagnies
d'assurance les hôteliers les guides les
intervenants de l'événementiel et c'est
tout ce secteur n'a plus aucune activité
un tiers de ce secteur peut faire
faillite dans les mois à venir
alors évidemment aujourd'hui le chiffre
n'a pas changé mais c'est demain que les
faillites vont arriver en cascade de ce
ministre au delà de l'existant du
chômage partiel et des prêts garantis
par l'état qui ont été déjà consommés a
aujourd'hui plus mois de mars
que proposez vous à ces petits chefs
d'entreprises qui n'ont pas ré
trésorerie pour survivre encore
longtemps ce qui est très important pour
eux c'est ce que vient de vous dire mon
confrère serge babary qu'en est il des
réductions de loyer pour lesquelles il
ya eu tant d'effets d'annoncé de la part
du premier ministre de la part du milieu
des finances
mais pour le moment malheureusement
aucun la ministre
kevin france passe ferrat pour clôturer
cette première série de la question
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre est bien difficile surtout
incompréhensible d'appréhender
l'entêtement du gouvernement la
situation à neda avait toujours mise en
avant c'est tout à fait normal mais nous
aussi sommes attachés autant que vous et
depuis le de confinement de mai les
commerçants ont pris des mesures
rigoureuses pour en assurer la sécurité
sanitaire et des efforts très importants
ont été faits monsieur ministre lê khac
au vide se rencontrent semble-t-il en
priorité dans le milieu professionnel
les pourcentages le montre pouvez vous
nous donner des chiffres 200 de cette
contamination dans les commerces
il ya un point que vous je souhaiterais
évoqué à cet instant il s'agit d'un
niveau sanitaire
j'ai cru comprendre ni ses ministres
qu'il existe une procédure idéal qui se
nomme tester alerté protéger mais je
voudrais vous en donner un exemple ça me
semble très important
j'ai un coach à détester gaulle vide le
vendredi 23 octobre et la prévenue tout
ce qu'il a approché et indiquant qu'un
appel de l'assurance maladie leur
seraient importés les premiers l'ont été
le dimanche le dernier le lundi
indiquant des dates de test à ce jour
tous n'ont pas les résultats
nous sommes le 2 novembre des sérieux
sont chez eux les autres dans la nature
et ce sont les commerçants qui paye le
plus fort de cette incapacité à suivre
ce procédé
bruno le maire me semble-t-il était
sensible à une réouverture sur rendez
vous par exemple et cela a été balayé
d'un revers de main ah j'oubliais
ministres les grandes surfaces ne
pourront plus vendre les produits
alors j'ai pas trouvé d'autre terme dits
essentiels
cela peut donner bonne conscience mais
quid des ventes en ligne évidemment on
ne va pas se fâcher avec les géo doutons
que l'on voudrait nous faire croire dans
le même temps qu'ils seront axés un jour
quelle hypocrisie
monsieur le ministre la gronde et forte
j'ai ministre je vous en prie soyez le
porte-parole des petites entreprises des
commerçants vous aviez cette
connaissance du terrain hier vous étiez
l'un d'eux je ne veux pas croire que
vous l'ayez déjà oublié parce qu'il ne
me nistre voilà une supplique qui vient
de la marne
voilà je tête vous laisser répondre à
ses premières questions
donc tu fumes permettent aux deux tu te
répondre à la dernière pour vous le dire
madame la sénatrice avec la plus grande
détermination
je n'ai pas oublié 40 ans d'artisanat me
suis installée en 1975 et donc je n'ai
pas oublié en quatre mois et demi
ministre et je n'oublierai jamais
quarante ans de ma vie ni les
problématiques ni les difficultés ni les
besoins de ces secteurs qui sont
nombreux permettez-moi une parenthèse
qui ont été rarement pris en compte tels
que ceux la majorité au pouvoir et qui
font que ces secteurs ont beaucoup
considéraient qu'il n'était pas
suffisamment accompagner donc je n'ai
rien oublié de tout ça et si le
président m'a demandé d'occuper cette
fonction c'est parce qu'il estime qu'il
faut avoir une action spécifique pour
ces entreprises et j'essaye au maximum
de trouver les solutions adaptées même
si la situation actuelle sanitaire nous
permet pas d'aller aussi vite que je
souhaiterais en tout cas je peux d'ores
et déjà vous dire qu'à côté de toutes
les mesures que nous prenons et tout le
travail que nous faisons sur l'urgence à
mon cabinet nous travaillons en
parallèle sur un certain nombre de
mesures qui vous seront j'espère assez
vite dévoilé pour accompagner de
transformer et essayer d'améliorer la
situation économique sociale fiscale et
réglementaire de ces trois millions d'
indépendants et donc naturellement
madame la sénatrice soyez assurés que
quel que soit le temps je sais bien que
le ton de vie d'un ministre est limité
quel que soit le temps pendant
lesquelles je puis pas cette fonction
je n'oublierai pas une seconde à la
forme au parcours et les mes anciens
collègues dans leur situation
ensuite bon je vais redire que
naturellement saubot naulleau mère et
moi nous avons beaucoup fait pour
essayer de maintenir l'ensemble des
activités économiques ouverte
encore une fois la situation sanitaire
et l'arbitrage qui a été donné en regard
du nombre très important de cas et des
risques absolument avéré que dans
quelques jours on est des problèmes
majeurs à l'hôpital ont amené le
président à prendre des décisions plus
naturellement
j'assume c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
nous avions prévu ce plan financier des
éléments extrêmement massive de
reconnaît qu on a sûrement et merci à
vous tous et tout d'y contribuer
beaucoup d'efforts à faire pour que les
mesures prises visant à atténuer en tout
cas son plan financier les difficultés
les entrepreneurs je pense qu'elles sont
ne sont pas encore intégrés par beaucoup
d'entre eux donc en ce qui me concerne
je vais faire beaucoup d'efforts pour
que tout ça soit bien connue parce que
naturellement c'est absolument
indispensable au minimum de les rassurer
sur ce sujet je redis que je vais dans
les prochains jours
recevoir toute la journée tous les
représentants du commerce des branches
professionnelles pour voir avec eux
toutes les solutions d'amélioration nous
permettant d'espérer le plus vite
possible une roue ouverture est donc
tout ce qui a été dit
sur le développement de la numérisation
sur les prises de commandes et toutes
autres dispositions possibles je m'en
rends je m'offrais le porte-parole
auprès du premier ministre du président
pour que naturellement tout ça sur pris
en considération sur la partie
numérisation
effectivement pour l'instant 100
millions qui sont immédiatement
disponibles à la fois pour accompagner
les collectivités qui mettent en place
des outils et quelquefois dans leur
commune dans leur pays
il ya vingt mille euros prévus par la
bande des territoires mais moi je suis
totalement disposé à regarder si on peut
améliorer ce montant financier
deuxième chose il ya eu effectivement
une proposition qui m'avaient été faites
pour accompagner d' imminente reprise
est déjà plusieurs semaines que j'ai
indiqué que ça me paraissait totalement
déconnecté des besoins et j'ai fixé à
voir la fin de l'année 2000 21 1
millions d'entreprises qui soit
digitaliser et numérisés et je travaille
tous les jours et contaminé pour qu'on
trouve le meilleur moyen de contacter
l'ensemble des entreprises quelle que
soit leur taille quelle que soit leur
territoire pour les accompagner dans
cette volonté de numérisation massive de
l'ensemble de cette entreprise en
précisant le dit monsieur sénateurs
laurent précisons bien que ça n'a pas
pour objet de remplacer le commerce
physique
1 j'habite une commune de 800 habitants
donc je sais très bien même si ses
proches d'une grande ville mais c'est
comme de 800 habitants et je connais je
crois c'est bien pour avoir beaucoup
dans mes fonctions précédentes sillonné
le territoire et compris les territoires
les plus ruraux pour savoir combien le
moindre commerce est essentiel dans ces
territoires ddt ou le ski a été lancée
sur les 222 coeur de ville d'où la
volonté du premier nice de relancer un
programme petite ville de demain est
naturellement doux tout ce que nous
essayons de mettre en place pour que il
n'y a pas d'effondrement de cette
économie et je redis que pour l'instant
même si le pour l'instant pour moi est
tout à fait essentiel il n'y a pas eu
défournement d'économies l'objectif
c'est bien d'essayer de maintenir au
maximum les l'économie française même si
je redis que ce maintien
n'empêche pas les difficultés mais en
tout cas c'est de maintenir
on a vu que lors de la reprise de
l'activité
le 11 mai l'activité économique avait
repris assez vite et assez fort parce
que justement les entreprises étaient
présents ensuite chez le sénateur
manuvie l'a évoqué les questions d des
protocoles naturellement dans les débats
que nous aurons avec les représentants
du commerce seront abordées les
questions de protocole est ce qu'il faut
en rajouter ou pas quel type de mesures
les questions de commandes et de
réservations seront un tutu en fait
comment il n'y a aucun sujet que je que
j'élimine par principe il faut
absolument qu'on regarde effectivement
si le virus est là encore pendant
plusieurs mois
il faut absolument que nous arrivions
avoir une économie qui tourne
quelle que soit la durée du virus
même la sénatrice heureux notamment à
rabieh bedian pardon excusez moi vous
avez évoqué les entreprises qui
n'étaient pas fermées par son ministre à
hâtive simplement vous rappeler qu'il y
à deux listes sas 1 bis et donc dans les
entreprises qui ne sont pas fermées
celles qui font moins de 50% de leur
chiffre d'affaires
nous avons enlevé tous les critères en
particulier de taille jusqu'à 50
salariés
celle qu'il faut moins de 50% qui doit
faire c'est un cas de beaucoup
malheureusement bénéficier au même titre
que les autres de la compensation de
10000 euros de chiffre d'affaires
exonérations de cotisations sociales et
activité partielle à 100 courses entre
temps qu'elle soit fermée de façon
administrative ou pas celles qui sont
dans la liste est simpliste qu'on a très
largement élargi depuis quelques
semaines on a encore rajouté la semaine
dernière donc c'est toutes les activités
liées de près ou de loin la culture au
sport à l'événementiel tous ces
activités là il ya plusieurs centaines
seront couverts de la même façon il n'y
est pas pour nous question et si dans
vos territoires
vous avez connaissance on l'a vu encore
la semaine dernière de telle ou telle
activité qui figurent pas dans cette
liste là je suis à votre disposition
sans aucun problème nous la rajouteront
vous avez évoqué les guides-interprètes
c'était moi même intervenir plusieurs
semaines ils ont été intégrés et il y en
a comme ça beaucoup donc naturellement
notre lectrice et de laisser tomber
aucune entreprise quelle que soit sa
taille quel que soit le territoire
concerné ça pour nous c'est absolument
indispensable
cernant les moyens financiers il est
évident c'est pas la peine de raconter
l'histoire que nous sommes pas en
situation de m 15 milliards par mois
pendant 6 mois ou six mois un an
bon je suis bien conscient que tout ça
naturellement aboutira un jour ou un
autre
à la question de la santé financière de
notre pays est dégradée depuis très
longtemps
de mémoire 1975 nous faisons des
déficits tous les ans et que le déficit
il est aujourd'hui très important et
donc naturellement nous allons très vite
mettre en place une commission qui sera
chargée de nous tracer des perspectives
budgétaires à plus long terme de voir de
quelle manière nous allons réussir à
gérer cette difficulté de la dette
française est là quelle manière nous
allons regarder à trouver des solutions
plus adaptées sans augmenter les impôts
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat ça a été
l'engagement qui a été pris par le
président pr ministre et bout de l'omert
et que naturellement nous souhaitons
appliquer donc pour l'instant nous avons
dit et nous parions sur le fait d'avoir
une croissance des économies
naturellement j'ai bien conscience celle
ci devrait avoir lieu qu'au moment où
nous serons plus 30e' avec le virus
je partage aussi je le redis je dis dans
mes premiers propos il est évident que
y'a pas les petits commerçants ne sont
pas fautifs de la situation je suis
d'accord pour dire que ma connaissance
oh je pense pas que c'est dans ces
petits magasins qui a plus de risques de
virus j'ai expliqué pourquoi au niveau
de la la santé il y avait eu beaucoup
d'insistance pour réduire le nombre de
lieux et accepter que dans ce domaine je
ne peux que me plier à la décision qui a
été prise sans avoir en ce qui me
concerne de d'éléments sur le plan
sanitaire à faire valoir
en ce qui concerne la tasse ghafour
rappeler que la france est le pays en
europe qui a été le plus en pointe sur
ce sujet c'est vrai sans avoir pour
l'instant malheureusement unanimité
européenne mais nous remonterons au
créneau très vite de façon à ce qu'il y
ait une juste fiscalisation de toutes
ses activités du numérique qui échappe
pour une très grande partie à la fois la
fiscalité et au quotidien social et ce
qui me concerne je vous dis très
directement
c'est totalement inacceptable il faut
qu'on trouve les moyens là aussi
l'équité de traitement fiscal et social
quelle que soit la manière dont
l'activité de vente de prestations de
services soient mises en oeuvre
c'est là aussi essentiel pour l'avenir
les consommateurs qui quelquefois mêmes
peuvent se plaindre de la fermeture de
tel ou tel commerce sont comme les
premiers à utiliser ces outils là donc
il est évident qu'il faut qu'on trouve
les moyens c'est pas facile
notre structure jédir l'agglo mentaires
fiscal mais pas adaptées aujourd'hui à
la situation de l'évolution
technologique et naturellement les
débats parlementaires peuvent utilement
contribuer à trouver les meilleures
solutions pour réussir à mettre ça en
place
peut-être juste pour pas être trop long
ou sénateurs babarit pour les 100
millions dans les prochains jours nous
allons très clairement indiqué la
manière dont nous allons contribuer à
accompagner les entreprises pour eux
cette numérisation digitalisation ou en
chèque numérique ou en crédit d'impôt
les derniers arbitrages sont pas faits
mais vont venir très rapidement
très bien merci nationalistes pour ses
premières réponses
j'engage et très nombreux collègues pour
prendre par là ou pas peut être dupliqué
les questions sur lesquelles les
stratégies a répondu la parole est à
michel bonnus ensuite à d'années
seulement
mechelle monsieur ministre madame merci
merci à mes collègues parce que je suis
restaurateur encore et les questions
qu'ils ont posées j'ai évolué
complètement la question parce qu'on se
retrouve tous lors du premier continent
nous avons appris à 8h à 20h à la
télévision que le 21 mai à 22h20 jeudi
fermée ça veut dire ont arrêté de servir
les gens à 22h pour fermer à minuit sont
obligés donc avec les clients qu'on
avait sur les bras donc c'est un mariage
ou pas mais ce n'est comme ça et je
parle pas des traders qui est très
impacté aussi ce soit
nintendogs leurs stocks sur le premier
déconfinement aucun protocole nous
avions en protocole entre les mains donc
on a été mise en difficulté très vite
par les forces de l'ordre
et c'est très difficile de reprendre ma
question est la suivante avez vous
anticipez autocall pour les commerçants
parce que chaque commerçant peut métier
particulier le boucher c'est un
restaurateur et le teinturier
c'est pas une maison devenue une salle
de sport ou un libraire il est bien
évident que dans mon corps de métier
qu'est la restauration il faut fabriquer
faut savoir où on va pour gérer les
stocks
il faut construire une carte est bien
entendu avoir des employés et savoirs et
savoir comment ça va commencer à évoluer
la deuxième question est il intervenu
dans quelles conditions va rouvrir
on a perdu au delà de la perte sèche
c'est la valeur vénale des entreprises
qui ont perdu on n'en parle pas trop
mais mais il faut vraiment de discuter
dessus et aujourd'hui les prises un
pacte et parce qu'il y en a que c'est la
retraite
aujourd'hui chaque commerce on a payé
on est en train de le payer ou et là on
est encore plus impactés parce que on se
dit qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça vaut
aujourd'hui et que ça avoir donné en
termes d'attractivité
merci monsieur le ministre de répondre à
ces questions parce qu'on joue ça va je
sens que ça vous tient à coeur
je sens que vous connaissez vous
connaissez vous connaissiez le métier
mais en tous les cas on a besoin d'avoir
des certitudes pour l'art en la reprise
merci ensuite sylvain broyer merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
bon je vais essayer de ne pas faire de
redites parce que effectivement beaucoup
de choses ont déjà été dites et je les
partage ans pour la plupart reviendrait
simplement sur une filière la filière
horticole qui est très durement touchée
parce que vous le savez c'est une
filière très saisonnière puisque les
plantations se sont en général au
printemps ou à l'automne
déjà lors du premier confinement cette
filière a déjà perdu 70% de son chiffre
d'affaires et on se demande comment elle
va ressortir après ce deuxième
confinement qui arrive vraiment encore
au sommet ou très mauvais moment donc à
la détresse de cette filière s'ajoutent
de la colère parce que comme pour
d'autres commerces il ya une distorsion
concurrence puisque les jardineries
elles peuvent rester ouverte et du fait
qu'elle puisse vendre de la nourriture
pour animaux elles vendent également des
plans donc là aussi distorsions de
concurrence qui ajoute qu'ils ajoutent
du malheur au malheur
l'autre question concernait plus
particulièrement les le commerce en
ligne mais ça on en a déjà pas mal parlé
et je constate que tout a coulé les
grandes surfaces se trouve un peu démuni
par rapport au commerce en ligne
c'est un peu dommage qu'elles n'aient
pas fait preuve d'un peu de compassion
par rapport aux petits commerces
précédemment donc on voit par là que ou
ne peut pas compter forcément sur les
acteurs mais que c'est à vraiment à
l'état de prendre ses responsabilités
pour que les concurrents se fasse de
manière
le plus loyal possible merci merci
daniel permet de dire à daniel que quant
aux enseignes de la grande distribution
au milieu de ce qui suit les systèmes
voix accueillir des petits commerçants
soit on soit dans leurs magasins
la parole est à sylviane noël ensuite
jean marc boyer sylviane alors on va
passer à jean marc boyer et on rentre
après 6,1 après jean-marc oui merci
la présidente bon moi j'ai deux
questions à monsieur le ministre la
première vous dites que vous êtes basé
sur des des éléments vous ne vous êtes
pas basée sur des éléments scientifiques
et médicaux pour une tête décision est
ce que il ya quand même des éléments qui
ont permis de décider de laisser
l'ouverture des grandes et moyennes
surfaces et la non couverture des petits
commerces
donc quelle différence sur un plan
sanitaire peut-on faire sur une dans une
grande surface avec un contrôle de jauge
tu peux être de 200 à 300 personnes même
si c'est une contrôlée selon la
superficie avec un petit commerce qui a
une petite superficie qui jusqu'ici
filtré ses clients si la suprématie des
piétons étaient à trois clients plus
importante cinq plus importants disent
avec le risque et des gestes barrières
donc il ya quand même des éléments qui
ont fait que dans le temps et dans
l'espace
on se permet de prendre des décisions
d'ouverture et de fermeture de cette
manière là donc
considérez vous que la grande
distribution peut faire mieux respecter
les règles et les barrières sanitaires
que petit commerce
moi je ne le pense pas mais bon vous
avez certainement des éléments par
rapport à ça ma deuxième question
concerne les conséquences sur le
tourisme et sur le thermalisme en
particulier vous savez que l'activité
thermale avait une prolongation en
accord à 4 nab de prolonger son activité
dans marca
fin novembre début décembre or la tente
où tombent par terre puisque avec le
confinement qui va durer au moins
jusqu'à la mi décembre
cette activité thermal va être
complètement stoppée elle est déjà
stoppée d'ailleurs donc environ 60 % ce
qui est considérable et ça concerne
quand même ça 10 110 stations thermales
en france avec de la clientèle qui est
en accompagnant les conséquences
indirectes qui sont très importantes sur
l'activité commerciale et artisanale
merci merci jean marc à sylviane n'est
pas revenue
donc je vais passer la parole à
catherine fournier et on finira avec
viviane artigalas oui merci madame la
présidente merci aux ministres eh bien
je ne vais pas reprendre tout ce que mes
collègues ont dit mais j'ai eu les mêmes
nombre de messages
ce que je voulais dire simplement
gemelli j'ai toujours apprécié votre
implication votre oeil
votre engagement auprès des commerçants
artisans je vous connais bien dans les
hauts de france et je connais cette
maîtrise par les toutefois de
compensation financière mais vous savez
également ce sont des mesures court
termiste vous le disiez si cela doit
durer plusieurs mois l'état serait dans
l'incapacité d'apporter un soutien si
dense et direct dans de mêmes
proportions
vous le savez les commerçants préfèrent
de loin exercer leur métier
même s'ils ont des conditions sanitaires
très strictes
c'est un principe chez les indépendants
bon il s'agit pas ici que dans les
circonstances d'opposer les différentes
formes de commerce
ce que je veux c'est éviter que de
privilégier les véritables gagnante que
sont les plateformes de e-commerce
internationales ont parlé des gamins qui
s'extrait des règles en vigueur
et je ne parle donc pas non plus de leur
extraction fiscales même si la france
est parmi les pays qui des taxes le plus
je veux dire par rapport à un
indépendant c'est sans commune mesure
bon c'est dans le ressenti de ces
commerçants ils sont mal comprises
accusent le gouvernement de considérer
la vente avec un traitement différencié
que vous soyez riche
puissant ou petits et faibles
modestement je me positionne sur la
défense des plus faibles
donc ma question est la suivante face à
ces mastodontes du commerce en ligne
pourquoi ne pas permettre aux
commerçants autorisé l'ouverture de
faire office de point relais pour les
commandes qui serait faite aux autres
commerçants considérés comme non
autorisée est situé dans le même
périmètre géographique je m'explique
ce sera une grande surface où est passé
commande vous allez à leurs sites leurs
situe alors shift brahim et vous prenez
vos commandes
amazon ils vous proposent soit une
livraison à domicile soit une livraison
au point relais
ainsi ce serait une alternative pour les
petits commerçants en plus de click and
collect de leur donner non seulement la
possibilité de se faire ce qu'elles
collectent six ont les capacités
numériques mais ô combien de s'organiser
entre eux sur un secteur à quartier et
surtout aussi de leur permettre de
s'entraîner en définissant un point
relais dans un magasin de produits frais
par exemple une boulangerie est ce qu'à
votre sens ce serait possible sans
passer par une plateforme qui leur
occasionnerait des frais supplémentaires
voilà ma question monsieur disponibles
la présidente du coe merci merci
catherine et pour finir cette série
viviane artigalas nous avons retrouvé
cigano même que dans la mare dans le
groupe suivant
viviane merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre nous l'avons dit
les commerces de proximité souvent
accompagné dé de leurs élus des élus de
nombreux élus se battent pour ne pas
fermer leur établissement
le ministre de l'économie avait
d'ailleurs plaidé pour une liste élargie
des magasins de commerce est essentielle
puis il a annoncé et j'ai le site de
nouvelles mesures permettant un retour à
l'équité entre les différents types de
commerces avant d'envisager un retour à
une ouverture plus large
il me semble que la demande le
communiqué de presse de l'association
des maires de france qui demandait la
révision de la définition de commerce
est essentielle
mais aussi l'amendement que nous avons
voté au sénat sur une réouverture de
certains établissements si les
conditions de sécurité sanitaires
permettent de préserver la santé de tous
en lui-même bien sûr avec les autorités
locales et signe il nous semblait que
ces mesures
répandez à ce que souhaitait le ministre
de l'économie il n'a pas été prouvé vous
nous expliquer le décalage qu'il ya
entre les annonces ce que voulait le
ministre de l'économie et les annonces
qui ont été faites par le premier
ministre il me semble que la question de
la santé des concitoyens n'est pas le
cas puisque ces commerces assure des
contrôles sanitaires extrêmement
importants qui ont des projets
importants dont vous pouvez vous nous
expliquer ce décalage entre ce qui était
demandé et les mesures annoncées et s'il
va y avoir un horizon sur ces mesures
pour nos commerces de proximité merci
messieurs ministre merci monsieur le
ministre vous répondre à cette série de
questions bien marrant car quelques
huiles derrière bien madame la
présidente monsieur le sénateur bonus
pour les des restaurateurs j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup rencontré beaucoup
travaillé sur la question de la
restauration
vous avez raison de dire que la décision
qui avait été plus mois de mars a été
trop brutale
c'était moi même au restaurant le samedi
soir je quittais restaurant 23h30 et mon
ami qui était fin mai juste après était
vraiment plus que dépité démoralisés
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que lorsqu'il y
avait eu une annonce de la fermeture des
restaurateurs à marseille elle nous
avons beaucoup travaillé avec la
préfecture pour que la décision de
fermeture soit pas applicable
le jeudi mais elle a été appliquée le
dimanche pour écouler ce qui avait été
commandé pour le week-end donc
naturellement vous avez raison il faut
respecter ces professionnels dire qu'il
y a eu vraiment quand je dire des
dispositions spécifiques
prise pour les restaurateurs j'ai encore
fait la semaine dernière une réunion
très très longue avec leurs
représentants du génie pour faire point
par point les sujets sur lequel il y a
eu des solutions et d'autres lequel y en
a pas eu je vais même vous voyez pas ce
que moi je souhaite travailler que vous
entre tacles transparence vous indiquez
les sujets sur lequel il n'y a pas
encore eu de leur point de vue
totalement satisfaction sur les loyers
puisque tout à l'heure j'ai pas
totalement répondu je m'en excuse sur
les loyers
soe loyer il y avait eu au mois de mai
juin une mission qui avait pour objectif
de trouver des solutions de médiation
force est de constater que la médiation
n'a pas donné les effets escomptés en
nombre de dossiers il y en a eu mais pas
suffisamment
c'est donc dès mon arrivée en accueil
bonneau mer créé en main cette question
des loyers en recevant à trois reprises
les bailleurs et en ayant des
concertations avec les locataires
vous savez toutes et tous ce sujet des
loyers sa complexité
c'était la variété d ailleurs entre les
foncières entre les concessions faites
par les mairies même l'état et entre la
très grande partie entre guillemets de
bailleurs privés qui sont souvent des
hommes et des femmes qui utilisent ce
loyer pour leur vie quotidienne
nous avions là beaucoup de difficultés à
trouver des solutions acceptables faire
cadeau des loyers aux entrepreneurs et
puis taper les bailleurs privés
s'étaient pas acceptable la dernière
réunion que j'ai tenus il ya une
quinzaine de jours j'ai indiqué aux uns
et aux autres que je proposerai que
j'allais pas continuer à les réunir en
des semaines sans trouver de solution je
proposerai une solution au premier
ministre bruno le maire
cette solution a été proposée un
arbitrage a été décidée l'abitrage
consiste à dire que pour le premier
dernier trimestre octobre novembre
décembre
sur les trois mois si li hao - moi ça
peut être trois mais s'il ya au moins un
mois
il est laissé sans loyer aux locataires
par le bailleur l'état prendra un tiers
en termes de crédit d'impôt de ce qui a
été enlevé aux locataires ces mesures
qui pour le bruit thème est évalué à un
milliard et demi
c'est une première mesure il faut
regarder
l'étiolement nous serons les coudes ce
que le sénat est d'assembler diront sur
cette mesure mais en tout cas moi j'ai
souhaité et bono maire est prémuni ce
qu'on ait un geste fait par les loyers
certains trouveront que ce n'est pas
suffisant d'autres que pour nous
écouterons les avis des uns des autres
enfin il ya une mesure qui est prise
deuxième mesure qui n'est pas encore du
point de vue des restaurateurs
correctement traités c'est la question
des congés payés sur l'activité
partielle et cette activité on est bien
conscient de ça et nous avons demandé
des deux bords de regarder ce sujet pour
voir de quelle manière on pouvait
éventuellement trouver une solution et
puis troisième sujet est moins dans
notre main mais sur lequel nous
intervenons et prie de me croire
il se passe pas une semaine sans lequel
j'étais bien sur le sujet c'est la
question de la perte d'exploitation au
niveau des assureurs bien aujourd'hui
nous avons fait une analyse il y à 7 %
des contrats d'assurance sur lequel il y
a plus ou moins la possibilité de mettre
en oeuvre la perte d'exploitation sur
ces 7 % il ya 3 % qui ont été payées par
les assureurs et 4% pour lequel il ya
encore ou des contestations des débats
en dehors de la situation actuelle nous
avons déjà eu plusieurs réunions avec
les réponses trop d'erreurs pour espérer
aboutir au début d'année prochaine sur
un nouveau risque pandémie moi j'ai
beaucoup insisté auprès des assureurs
pour qu'il n'y ait pas pour ce nouveau
risque
d'abord des cotisations qui serait
inacceptable pour les entrepreneurs
ensuite des risques qu'il y ait encore
des contestations sur le fait s'il ya
quelque chose ce soit ou pas accepté et
donc si le gouvernement donnera son
accord sur ce risque si on est vraiment
garantie que il n'y aura pas demain de
risque d'hésitation ou de sujets à
controverse la polémique sur les
assureurs d'une continuer à travailler
je t'ai de fermer un complément pour
dire également que je travaille avec
l'assurance crédit qui pour moi est un
vrai sujet en france et sur lequel en ce
qui me concerne j'ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises puis s'était
totalement insatisfaits de la façon dont
s'était passé la couverture de
l'assurance crédit
pendant cette période en ce qui concerne
ce qu'a dit madame la sénatrice fournier
ne le remercie d'avoir dit que nous
avions c'est vrai et je remercie
également beaucoup travaillé ensemble
depuis quelques années et je sais
qu'elle a toujours été à mon écoute et
je le choisis est d'autant plus avec
quelques hommes se seraient que chacun
d'entre vous moi je suis pas opposé sur
le principe de dire qu'il pourrait avoir
des points relais permettant à
l'ensemble des petits commerçants de
pouvoir développer leurs activités
la présidente je suis à titre personnel
un peu plus réservé que ces points
puisse être dans les lieux de grande
distribution
bon les poules dans le dans le
poulailler avec le renard autour les
poules sont restés ramant vivante
donc je suis pas sûr que de de faire
aller encore plus dans la grande
distribution les consommateurs pour
aller retirer les les produits des
petits commerces à soi une solution mais
j'ai entendu vos propositions qui j'en
suis pas convaincu pour l'instant on
je suis pas buté par principe
donc j'ai goûté jeu j'en parlerai avec
l'ensemble des composantes du commerce
que j'ai recevoir ou regarder si en ce
qui les concerne et tout ça bien s'y
trouve ça bien
j'y mettrai pas un blocage de principe
j'ai simplement dit un avis
mais mon avis il n'a pas plus dans ce
domaine d'intérêt que les leurs je
voudrais revenir monsieur le sénateur
bonus sur les questions de la valeur
vénale des entreprises c'est un vrai
sujet bon vous connaissez mon métier
d'origine
vous savez ce que les licences de taxis
à paris ont perdu deux valeurs avec
l'arrivée d'hubert donc je connais bien
un sujet qui pour l'instant n'est pas
traitée elle risque entrepreneurial
c'est pas satisfaisant comme répond j'en
ai bien conscience mais je connais assez
bien sujet vous n'allez plus parler des
prêteurs j'ai fait au moins une dizaine
de réunions avec des représentants des
traiteurs et les semaine dernière je
pense qu'on leur a trouvé en tout cas
une partie de solution par
l'intermédiaire de la bpi
nous avons appelé 170 traiteur
individuellement pour regarder avec eux
comment on pouvait les accompagner avec
des outils de prêts de l'état ou
d'accompagnement financier de l'état
pour leur permettre de passer un moment
dont je sais qui est douloureux ils ont
perdu 90 à 95 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires donc les traiteurs en tant
que tels sont accompagnés spécifiquement
on regarde leurs spécificités de leurs
métiers et je partage avec vous le fait
que chaque métier différent
c'est pour ça que j'ai reçu les
discothèques en un dispositif
discothèque
j'ai reçu les traiteurs j'ai reçu les
agences de voyages j'ai reçu les forains
et beaucoup de l'autre on qu'on puisse
travailler je dirais cousu main avait
chaque secteur pour trouver des
solutions les plus adaptées
même si je suis bien conscient que ça au
bout du compte est compliquée et le fait
que nous travaillons sur des codes naf
est quelque chose d'extrêmement complexe
parce qu'on peut très bien créer une
entreprise avec un code et puis
l'activité change au cours de la vie de
l'entreprise
et naturellement on n'est plus tout à
fait dans la même situation et ont créé
ce que j'appelle des trous dans la
raquette
donc tous aussi bien conscience tous les
jours j'ai des situations qu'on essaie
de regarder
pour monsieur le sénateur boyer bon y
est évident qu'il faut qu'on ait un
contrôle et rigoureuse sur les jauges
dans la grande distribution
je vais pas vous dire parce que ce
serait contraire à ma philosophie
il ya plus de risques d'attraper le
virus dans un petit commerce
bah c'est vrai j'ai pas vous dire parce
que c'est pas démontré qu'en suis pas
convaincu donc je peux pas vous dire le
contraire
par contre il y à un élément qui a été
mis en avant par l'ensemble des
scientifiques des médecins des
spécialistes que je ne suis pas comme
quoi pour réussir à diminuer le virus il
fallait diminuer les points de contact
voilà je vous le dis tel quel nous dit
elle qu'elle
c'est la raison qui a amené la fermeture
de deux points de contact et donc de
commerce qui tel quel et je reconnais
mon incompétence totale dans ce domaine
encore une fois il ya eu un arbitrage
mon rôle ici à bercy
c'est l'arbitrage étant donné d'essayer
au maximum d'accompagner et de compenser
la perte de ces commerçants en ce qui
concerne le tourisme et le thermalisme
ce sont des activités qui sont prises
dans les activités et ce à un service
donc ils bénéficient des mêmes aides que
les autres activités
moi je suis tout à fait à votre
disposition pour regarder avec
jean-baptiste lemoyne mon collègue au
tourisme de quelle manière on pourrait
accompagner aussi spécifiquement ses
activités essentielles pour notre pays
bon madame la sénatrice artigalas second
chez répondu tout à l'heure pour la
proposition le sénat la position du
gouvernement dans un premier temps a été
de dire au regard de la diffusion du
virus
il fallait mieux avoir une position
nationale identique partout on sait de
la position qui était prise
maintenant en ce qui concerne de
commerce non essentiels je redis que
c'est pas le terme que je souhaite qu'on
utilise
moi je dis qu'il faut bien distinguer
les pros
puis de première nécessité je pense que
tout - tc d'accord pour dire c'est
d'abord la nourriture si tout ce qui
concerne les produits liés à la santé et
pour d'hygiène donc nous sommes en train
actuellement de travailler avec les
différentes branches de façon à ce que
ce soit un décret sorte au préciser
quels sont ces produits de première
nécessité qui restent ouverts de façon
équivalente
quel que soit le mode de commerce
très bien merci monsieur le ministre
nous avons dernier resserrer un peu
longuet se rendra donc avec oleg grams
ans à un propos aussi et bien cibler la
parole boga sylviane noëlle v avec une
connexion qui s'est perdue dans la
montagne et en afrique
anne catherine loisier merci madame la
présidente monsieur ministre genre de
question à vous soumettre la première
question concerne les agents immobiliers
qui ne font pas partie des activités
interdites mais qui sont toutefois privé
de réaliser les visites des biens qu'ils
ont à vendre si les visites virtuelles
peuvent effectivement constituer une
alternative je pense que personne n'est
prêt à s'endetter sur 20 ans pour
l'achat d'un logement qu'il n'aura pas
pu voir de ses propres yeux
or l'immobilier est une nécessité dans
un grand nombre de cas en cas de
mutation du décès divorce etc
dès lors cette profession se voit
doublement pénalisés puisque en n'étant
pas considérée comme une activité
interdite
elle se verra écarté de fait deux